>> LEE ZELDIN, HE MAKES IT
SOUND LIKE KATHY HOCHUL GETS UP
EVERY MORNING, GOES TO THE
NEAREST SUBWAY STOP AND HANDS
OUT BILLY CLUBS AND BASEBALL
BATS TO EVERYBODY THAT GETS ON
THE SUBWAY.
LOOKS LIKE HE'S AUDITIONING TO
REPLACE WAYNE JOHNSON IN ALL
THOSE MOVIES.
RACHEL:  THAT WAS FORMER
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON, MOCKING
HE LEE ZELDIN AND FRANKLY THE
NEW YORK VOTEERS AS HE CAMPAIGNS
FOR NEW YORK GOVERNOR HE HOCHUL
IN ONE OF THE SLOWEST WATCHED
GOVERNOR RACES IN THE COUNTRY.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE PULLING OUT
ALL THE STOPS WITH VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS AND HILLARY
CLINTON RALLYING FOR HOCHUL LAST
WEEK AND PRESIDENT BIDEN SET TO
JOIN THEM LATER THIS EAVE A
THING.
>> WILL IT HELP?
JOINING US NOW, ANCHOR AND
EXECUTIVE EDITOR OF THE STORY
AND SHE'LL BE DOING A LOT OF
ELECTION COVERAGE AS WELL,
MARTHA MacCALLUM.
IF THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN NEW YORK
DEFENDING A CANDIDATE THERE,
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
HOW THEY FEEL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN.
>> THAT TELLS YOU A LOT,
OBVIOUSLY.
THEY HAD TO BRING IN THE BIG
GUNS OVER THE WEEKEND TO TRY TO
SAVE KATHY HOCHUL.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT GOES
THROUGH MY MIND AS I WATCH BILL
CLINTON, BILL CLINTON USED TO BE
THE BEST CLOSER OF ALL TIME IN
POLITICS.
HE REALLY HELPED TO SAVE
PRESIDENT OBAMA IN HIS SECOND
ELECTION WHEN HE CAME OUT AND
SAID NOBODY COULD HAVE FIXED THE
ANY THAT AMOUNT OF TIME, NOT
EVEN ME -- FIXED THE ECONOMY IN
THAT AMOUNT OF TIME, NOT EVEN
ME.
EVERYBODY IN THE NEW YORK
AUDIENCE IS LISTENING TO THIS.
THERE WERE PEOPLE CLAPPING BUT
THIS IS NOT FUNNY.
THERE'S NOTHING FUNNY ABOUT THIS
AND PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
THEIR HEART IN THEIR THROAT WHEN
THEY GO INTO THE SUBWAY, THEY'RE
NOT LAUGHING WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT HANDING OUT BILLY CLUBS,
KATHY HOCHUL AND LEE ZELDIN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE LEFT NEW
YORK BECAUSE THEY DON'T FEEL
SAFE AND OTHER REASONS THAT
HAPPENED DURING COVID.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S AN ON
TARGET CLOSING ARGUMENT FOR HIM.
RACHEL:  I FELT LIKE OBAMA WAS
RUSTY TOO.
I WASN'T IMPRESSED WITH HIS HER
FORM MAN'S ON THE TRAIL EITHER.
-- PERFORMANCE ON THE TRAIL
EITHER.
HISPANICS WILL BE AN IMPORTANT
SWING VOTE IN THE ELECTION IN
MANY STATES.
THE ATLANTIC WROTE A GREAT
ARTICLE, I THOUGHT IT WAS
FASCINATING, HAD SOME PEOPLE
THAT WE'VE HAD ON THE SHOW
FEATURED IN THIS VERY LONG PIECE
TALKING ABOUT WHY DEMOCRATS ARE
LOSING HISPANIC VOTERS.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
FROM THAT PIECE.
IT SAYS HISPANICS HAVE HE BEGUN
ABANDONING THE DEMOCRAT PARTY,
DEFYING GENERATIONS OF POLITICAL
PATTERNS, THE VERY THING THAT
BREATHES LIFE INTO THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY 20 YEARS AGO.
THE FOCUS ON IDENTITY AND
INCLUSION IS MAKING IT MORE
POPULAR WITH WHITE VOTERS AND
LESS POPULAR WITH HISPANIC
VOTERS.
MARTHA.
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT HAS HAPPENED
OVERNIGHT.
THIS HAS BEEN HAPPENING OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST 10, 12 YEARS.
AND WE'VE BEEN WATCHING THE
HISPANIC NUMBERS MOVE WITH EVERY
ELECTION.
AND THE BLACK VOTER NUMBERS HAVE
MOVED WITH EVERY ELECTION AS
WELL.
IT'S JUST A SMALL PIECE THAT HAS
GROWN OVER TIME.
YOU KNOW, I THINK -- YOU TALK
ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME, RACHEL.
BUT I THINK THAT HIS HISPANIC VS
LIKE THE GREAT IMMIGRANT GROUPS
THAT CAME BEFORE THEM, AT SOME
POINT YOU BECOME AMERICANS AND
CARE ABOUT THINGS THAT ALL
AMERICANS TALK ABOUT.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT IRISH AND
ITALIAN VOTERS ANYMORE.
HIT PANIC VOTERS CARE ABOUT THE
SAME THINGS, EDUCATION, SAFETY
AND THE ECONOMY.
WHEN YOU TALK TO THEM AS IF
THEY'RE ALWAYS GOING TO BE ON
YOUR SIDE AND WILL ALWAYS CARE
ABOUT ONE THING WHICH IS LETTING
EVERYBODY COME ACROSS THE
BORDER, YOU'RE LOSING THEM.
RACHEL:  THEY'RE WORKING CLASS
VOTERS.
I THINK THE DEMOCRAT PARTY KEEPS
TALKING IN RACIAL TERMS AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY ABOUT CLASS.
AND WORKING CLASS PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE THEIR
VALUES ARE WORKING CLASS VALUES.
I THINK THEY SEE SO MANY OF THE
ELITE AS AN ASSAULT ON THEM.
>> IT'S THE PARTY OF MORE
PROGRESSIVE AND WEALTHY VOTERS.
RACHEL:  THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THAT'S A BIG SHIFT.
WE SEE SHIFTS IN AMERICAN
POLITICS.
THEY HAPPEN EVERY 20, EVERY 30
YEARS AND THEY'RE BIG WHEN THEY
HAPPEN AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
STORY LINES THAT WE'RE GOING TO
WATCH REALLY CLOSELY TO SEE IF
IT DOES BEAR OUT WHEN WE SEE THE
NUMBERS ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
>> ON THE OTHER HAND, THEY HAVE
THIS CLOSING MESSAGE.
WATCH THIS.
>> [SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
>> THE DIVERSITY OF THIS
COMMUNITY AS UNIQUE AS THE
BREAKFAST TACOS HERE IN SAN
ANTONIO.
>> THERE YOU GO.
DANCE WITH ME, COME ON.
>> SO SAY IT WITH ME.
[SPEAKING IN SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
>> MARTHA, I THINK --
RACHEL:  WE SAY IN SPANISH --
[SPEAKING IN SPANISH].
SO BAD.
>> 10 YEARS AGO SOMEONE COULD
HAVE PEAKED THE CASE THAT
REPUBLICANS' POLITICAL INSTINCTS
WERE OFF, HOW THEY WERE TRYING
TO CONNECT WITH VOTERS.
THIS REVEALS AN INSTINCT AND
PROBABLY PERSONALITIES, WE TALK
ABOUT LOSERS OUT THERE, BRAT
BETO O'ROURKE -- BETO O'ROURKE,
HOW HOW LONG DO LONG DO -- HOW
LONG DO YOU GET TO BE A STAR.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AT ROMNEY
AND RYAN, AFTER THEY LOST THE
ELECTION, THERE WAS A HUGE
RE-EVALUATION THAT WAS DONE IN
REPUBLICAN POLITICS AND THEY
REALIZED THAT THEY WERE LOOKING
AT, YOU KNOW, A VERY SORT OF
WHITE UPPER MIDDLE CLASS KIND OF
UNIVERSE AND THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY WERE EVEN RECRUITING AS
CANDIDATES.
YOU LOOK AT WHO IS OUT THERE AS
CANDIDATES THIS TIME AROUND,
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE STEPPING UP TO
RUN SO I THINK THAT YOU'RE
SEEING THAT KIND OF EVOLUTION
THAT'S HAPPENING AND I THINK --
I MEAN, THOSE CLIPS THAT YOU
JUST PLAYED ARE VERY
EMBARRASSING, THEY'RE PANDERING
AND THEY'RE --
RACHEL:  HISPANDERRING.
>> THEY MAKE YOU UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> THAT PIVOT FOR REPUBLICANS,
I THINK TO BE FAIR IT THOSE BE
SAID WAS MADE SEVEN YEARS AGO.
IT WAS MADE WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> IT SURE WAS.
>> THE CANDIDATES THAT ARE NOW
SEEMING TO HIT BETTER POLITICAL
INSTINCTS ARE THOSE, BLAKE
MASTER, KARI LAKE, RON DE
SANTIS, THEY'RE FOLLOWING IN THE
WAKE OF DONALD TRUMP AND IT'S
THE REPOSITIONING BACK TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
RACHEL:  TO THE WORKING CLASS.
>> KEVIN MCCARTHY HAD A LOT TO
DO WITH THAT AS WELL, RECRUITING
CANDIDATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT'S SOMETHING HE'S WORKED HARD.
RACHEL:  KEVIN MCCARTHY'S ROLE
IN CANDIDATE RECRUITMENT IS
ENORMOUS AND UNDER APPRECIATED.
>> THE PARTY KNEW THEY HAD TO
REORIENT.
AMNESTY AT FIRST AND DONALD
TRUMP SAID HOW ABOUT WE SECURE
THE BORDERS.
RACHEL:  TURNS OUT PEOPLE ON THE
BORDER WANT TO SECURE THE BORDER
AND THEY TEND TO BE HISPANIC.
>> YOU'VE GOT BIG COVERAGE COME
UP, WHAT DO YOU HAVE AND WHEN.
>> BRETT AND I WILL BE ON
TONIGHT WITH THE FULL PANEL WHO
WILL BE HERE ON TUESDAY NIGHT
WHICH IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT
THIS YEAR SO I THINK YOU'LL HEAR
A LOT OF GREAT DISCUSSION LIKE
WE'RE HAVING THIS MORNING WITH
THE ENTIRE GROUP.
THAT IS AT 10:00 TONIGHT.
WE'LL BE ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY ON
THE PANEL WITH SHANNON BREAM
THIS MORNING AS WELL WHICH AIRS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WHENEVER
YOU GET FOX NEWS SUNDAY.
SO BIG DAY.
WE'RE EXCITED.
>> IT'S A LIVE FULL REHEARSAL.
>> EXACTLY.
>> WE GET A HE REVIEW.
>> ANYTHING WE SCREW UP TONIGHT
WE'LL FIX BY TUESDAY.
>> THAT'S LIKE THE FIRST TWO
HOURS OF THIS SHOW EVERY
WEEKEND.
>> EXACTLY.
RACHEL:  SO GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GREAT TO